Hey guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop in the past
We've done a few different experiments casting candy into some different shapes we did grant and my thumb
We did a giant turkey out of melted Jolly Ranchers, and we also made some silver play buttons cast in candy well today
We're going to try something a little different
All of those previous experiments have been solid candy all the way through when they were cast today
I wanted to try something a little bit different
It's called slush casting or rotation casting the basic idea is we'll whip up a batch of our hard candy
And then we've got two of these things which you might recognize as our pokeball molds now
I'm not going to try and make a solid pokeball of candy that would weigh about a pound
You'd be almost impossible to eat and it'd kind of be a waste of candy so what we are gonna try and do is
See if we can pour the liquid candy down into the mold and then
Rotate it around to coat all of the sides of the mold as the candy cools off
Hopefully the result will be a hollow
Pokeball made out of candy here are the supplies that we're going to need to try this experiment
We're gonna need some corn syrup some white sugar a pot to cook everything in our flavoring and food coloring
and of course the pokeball molds
It's also important to make sure you have a working candy thermometer to get the temperature right as you're cooking
We have everything ready. Let's get some candy cooking on the stove this candy recipe is very basic. It's two cups of white sugar
2/3 cups corn syrup and
3/4 cups of water there we have it all three of our ingredients in the pot
I'm just doing a little bit of mixing and then I'm gonna put it on the stove
Over medium heat stir the mixture with a heat-safe spatula until all of the sugar is dissolved
Once your sugar is completely dissolved
It's time to stop stirring
the candy thermometer should be attached to the side of the pot in such a way that the bottom of the
Thermometer is in the candy mixture
But not touching the walls
Or the bottom of the pot it will take some time for your candy to heat up to the right temperature
But just be patient make sure you watch the candy thermometer well so that you don't accidentally burn it
While our candy is cooking
I just want to prep our molds really quickly these are two part molds that come apart completely
So I'm just gonna wrap some rubber bands around them to hold them nice and closed when we pour in the candy
once our candy mixture hits
260 degrees Fahrenheit, it's time to add some food coloring
But still don't stir it
Let the boiling action of the sugar do that for you the moment your candy hits 300 degrees Fahrenheit?
you need to remove it from the heat at this point our candy is completely cooked and
We're just gonna let it cool down a little bit to let some of the bubbles disappear
Before we pour it into our pokeball molds
And as we let it cool down just a bit to get all the bubbles out. We're gonna add our flavor
And so I'm just kind of guessing how much I'm going to need I haven't tried this before so I'm not exactly sure how well
It'll work
Got our hot handy down inside the mold now. I'm just gonna try and rotate it evenly
So it coats everything as it cools down put this plate under me
So if it spills out and mouth doesn't get all over the counter
It was starting a spill
So at this point everything that I can see inside the mold is nice and well coated
I just have to hope that the parts that I can't see the very edge near the opening of the mold are also well coated
Kind hard as hell
Also, we've got these nice little slivers of candy
I'm gonna take my mold and while the candy has mostly cooled off. It is still
running very very slowly inside
So I'm just gonna take this and set it upside down so if there is any extra
It will run out the mouth onto the plate, and it won't pool too much anywhere inside the mold now
I'm just gonna take the rest of the candy and pour it into this one
You're doing a slush casting or rotation casting as is also called
It's important to keep it moving pretty much the whole time so that it coats it evenly inside
Candy is going to be a little bit different than most types of things
I've done slush casting with them before I've used several different types of resin in molds like this to make
Little props or pieces of costumes and stuff like that this is definitely different, but I'm hoping the principles will work out the same way
That's looking pretty good. I'm gonna do the same thing with this one
We're just gonna turn it upside down on a plate if there is any excess. It'll drain out
And we'll hope it cools down nicely
To help him cool down. I'm just gonna pop them into the fridge
Alright, we've got the pokéballs cooling down in the refrigerator and while that happens
I actually have something else that I want to try slush casting
It's gonna be a little bit of a surprise when I reveal it to see what it is
I've made if you have any guesses about what this is before I cast it. Let us know down in the comments
No cheating and watching the whole video and then commenting what it actually is. Yeah guess first and then watch
I'll start mixing up another batch of candy and get it cooking
Oh, yeah absolutely good
It's a little messy in a couple spots but most part
I'm liking how that looks
And tastes
Very warm in there
little bits of the candy are still like
Soft enough for they're kind of slumping inside their you know I have a different idea
So this freezer for whatever reason has a whole lot of old?
frozen bananas in it and while I certainly wouldn't want to eat them I
Think they will work to help cool down what I'm casting here, so I'm just gonna kind of fill this
cavity
with some frozen bananas
Just as ice packs
One of the strangest things I've ever done
Yep full of bananas
Trash cans just hold that upright as it cools down and once it's cooled down all the way
We'll try and de mold it and see if it turned out. Let's see if the pokeballs have finished
You definitely had some extra sugar in this one kind of pour it out and left a little puddle on the plate
Feels pretty nice and cool and rigid inside so I think we're good this one. Oh this one
Also had a little bit of a looks like a weird
Boozy slug tongue or something I don't know see if we can de mold these without destroying them that might be the real question
I don't know how thick
The candy will have built up on the walls, so maybe it's thick enough that it will hold itself together
And maybe it'll just shatter apart as I try and open it to be a real shame
Don't hear any shattering noise. It's good sign Oh
Beautiful
Yes
Oh
It's fantastic. Let's try the other one I
Think there was less candy in this one. So it might even be a little thinner
If yes
Hah
Look at that
hard candy pokin oh
That's fantastic. I'm gonna get a pair of pliers and see if I can break off the little
Tumors going on the back of these things all right, so I want to get this separate chunk of candy off
But I don't want to shatter the rest of pokeball. I don't know how fragile it is
I don't think we need to see but I can break off a little piece of it I
Should come off really nicely
All right that actually worked pretty well better than I thought it would ha there's one see about this other one Oh
See that's what I was kind of worried about it broke into the body of the pokeball just a little bit. It's not bad
It's definitely not ruined. It's not quite as clean as I was hoping so there we go to hollow
Candy pokey balls picked up pretty good detail there were a couple spots where the candy didn't cast beautifully into the mold
We've got these little bubbles and of course
There's also some surface bubbles all over the outside of it, but for the most part BAM. It's pretty dang good. I think
When we cast our Thanksgiving turkey lollipop it had sort of a flat outside color
But hitting with a blowtorch really helped smooth it out
I'm gonna see if I can do something similar with the pokey balls to see if they get a little bit more transparent
That's working pretty good, I think
Alright, I definitely think that helped a little bit, you can see that this one is now more clear
You can see down through it pretty nicely. There's still lots of bubbles in the way well
I think that worked well enough. I'm going to do it on the other one too
You would be cooler of course if I could make the candy match the color of the pokeball in all the different spots
But slush casting doesn't really let you choose
What color goes where it's sort of a 1 in color goes everywhere?
And then if you want to color it afterward you do that I might have to do some research into how to paint sugar
How bad
It's not painting it, but you know it tastes good. I've actually got this little
Charizard keychain thing
And I want to open up the bottom of one of these pokeballs just enough that I can fit this inside there
Just because I think that would look really cool
haha
Well there we go
Think our casting has cooled down enough that it's rigid, and I can now take it out of the mold
So I'm just gonna take the bananas out of it like you do
Here goes
At this point some of you might be able to figure out what it is unmaking
Ha ha it's working
It worked a candy Iron Man helmet
Sweet that is beautiful oh
man
Tony Stark only wishes
alright there we go a
100%
Candy Iron Man helmet this is fully to scale
So many years ago, I made myself an Iron Man costume
And that involves sculpting molding and casting a helmet
So I still have the mold which is what I've been using and I'd cleaned it out really well
and then I cast candy into it and
Now I have a candy Iron Man helmet, and I want to put it on but unfortunately
I don't think my head will actually fit in this design is meant to have a piece of it
Removable to put it over your head
No like that's that's as far as I get right there sadly very sadly I
Can't actually wear this Iron Man. Helmet. Maybe if I had a head much much smaller than
I'd be able to so like a small child might be able to get this on might be worth looking into is weird
But it's made of candy
So I got a lick it
I'm sorry Tony, sorry
That's delicious
Alright guys this has been an excellent experiment learning if we can do slush casting or
Rotational casting using a candy recipe and it worked surprisingly well
We've got our two pokeballs, and we have our candy Iron Man helmet, and they all work great
There are little difficulties of course tiny bits of cracking bubbles in the surface
But overall this definitely works as a casting material, and it's delightful. It looks really cool
It's probably the best-tasting thing you could probably use as a slush casting material
I was a little bit afraid that they would just sort of shatter when they're cooling down
Structurally speaking melted sugar is fairly similar to melted glass
They are both
What's called an amorphous solid which means they form a non crystalline lattice structure as they cool down and?
glass if you were to try and cast like this one thing it wouldn't stick to the walls at all
And another as it was cooling down if you don't put it in a kiln and very slowly cool it down
It would definitely crack, so I was a little bit worried that the sugar would do the same thing
But this has worked quite well coming from a prop in costume making background
That's just a really fun thing to try
I've done several slush castings with different types of resin, but this is a new frontier for me
Thank you guys for joining us for this project today, and we look forward to the next one talk to you then
Now you can go out and catch all of the candy pokemon that are running around your neighborhood
Candy Pikachu I choose you
But that's not catching. That's what
Hey guys
Did you know that we're on Twitter Instagram and Facebook as well all at the king of random and every platform has a different purpose
So go scroll through the histories check out what we're doing. I'll see you there